syndicats ont été suspendus tard hier
soir la direction maintient son
programme pour demain en principe un vol
sur deux devrait être assuré et
vraisemblablement un vol sur 3 vendredi
à quatre jours du premier tour visite
hautement symbolique de danielle
mitterrand auprès de six étrangers
parents d'enfants de nationalité
française en grève de la faim depuis
huit jours
cela pour exprimm pour demander exiger
même le règlement de leur situation
reportage maryse burgot giron portique
c'est une de ses visites auxquelles
danielle mitterrand a habitués la presse
ces dernières années mais celle ci est
sans doute la dernière en tant que
première dame de france
une dernière tout symbolique les pousses
du président a choisi aujourd'hui de
venir écouter des étrangers en grève de
la faim tous condamnent les lois pasqua
sur l'immigration et d'un an mitterrand
est venu dire qu'elle soutient leur
combat je suis solidaire de ces gens qui
se trouvent qu'ils se trouvent dans une
souricière
et c'est sûr mais c'est de de desserrer
les dents de cette souricière c'est tout
c'est tout ce que j'essaie de faire ici
il va appeler ça de la politique si vous
voulez de l'instant où où le sort de
ceux qui vous entourent vous touche bien
on devrait tout faire de la politique en
effet c'est ainsi que danielle
mitterrand aura marqué les deux
septennats de son mari par des
engagements politiques au nom de la
fondation qu'elle a créée
france libertés soutien au peuple kurde
visite au salvador soutien au peuple
sahraoui
des positions qui n'auront pas toujours
été du goût de tous il est vrai que
quelquefois en défendant ses causes
justes j'ai mis le gouvernement en
difficulté en ce sens que
nous prenions des dépositions qui
pouvaient gêner une diplomatie ou une
économie ou d où le gouvernement conduit
c'est à l'époque je ne sais pas si vous
vous souvenez en 1981 quand françois
était vous pouvoir sa première une de
ses premières paroles c'était de dire
tout pouvoir doit susciter son
contre-pouvoir et quel meilleur contre
pouvoir que la vie à de la vie
associative et l'opinion publique
eh bien je je suis entré de plain pied
dans ce contre-pouvoir là dans le bureau
de l'épousé du président il y à ces
objets rapportés du monde entier et il y
à un portrait celui de pierre bérégovoy
sa disparition aura été l'un des moments
les plus difficiles de ses années
passées aux côtés de françois mitterrand
le franc français a continué de baisser
c'est une de ses visites donc elles
danielle mitterrand a habitués la
retraite ces dernières années mais celle
ci la dernière en tant que première dame
de france
une dernière tout symbolique les pousses
du président a choisi aujourd'hui de
venir écouter de l'étranger en grève de
la faim
tous condamnent les lois pasqua sur
l'immigration et d'un an et demi terrain
à de nous dire qu'elle soutient leur
combat je suis solidaire de ces gens qui
se trouvent eux qui se trouve dans une
souricière
et ce geste on essaye de de desserrer
les dents de cette souricière c'est tout
c'est tout ce que j'essaye de faire ici
il va appeler ça de la politique si vous
voulez de l'instant où où le sort de
ceux qui vous entourent vous touche bien
on devrait tous ceux de la politique en
effet c'est ainsi que danielle
mitterrand aura marqué les deux
septennats de son mari par des
engagements politiques ou non de la
fondation qu'elle a créée france
libertés soutien au peuple kurde visite
au salvador soutien au peuple sahraoui
des positions qui n'auront pas toujours
été du goût de tous il est vrai que
quelquefois en défendant ses causes
justes gémit
le gouvernement en difficulté en ce sens
que nous prenions des dépositions qui
pouvaient gêner une diplomatie ou une
économie ou d où le gouvernement conduit
à l'époque je ne sais pas si vous vous
souvenez en 1981 quand françois était
vous pouvoir sa première une de ses
premières paroles c'était de dire tout
pouvoir doit susciter son contre-pouvoir
et quel meilleur contre-pouvoir que la
vie à la vie associative et l'opinion
publique
eh bien je je suis entré de plain pied
dans ce contre pouvoir là dans le bureau
de l'épousé du président il y à ces
objets rapportés du monde entier et il y
à un portrait celui de pierre bérégovoy
sa disparition aura été l'un des moments
les plus difficiles de ses années
passées aux côtés de françois mitterrand